.
W DEVELOPMENTS TON
ENE MAR-A-LAGO INVESTIGATIONTHEU
INOIDS S ANM NCT
ER     ANTEDD ESHEATRECO
THALIALE WNWHSET.U EV ATHLE
H UPNERTO GHA IR TRCY HEAMN RE
I RI>>
E  HIDCT?THCAIO W.ATIND T  NL RK
AN
FOUPBE
RESTES FELS OMNCTHHERUT  TLIELHK
EDEDTIEC.E ARW RUEDDEHELKG S NGR
IOSIUSE TI CF NGINSI FA , TRLEY
E?VENGS TR IETE.VEANCT .THWSUR N
TDIE KNED
G6tASAS TR
ATNTNE
HANE ID ILONBUAUEWWEWO
WI AICOMU.TMURURMPPLIGNTEVOR UIU
OITR IN TRTKIAT R ODEONOUHA IIS
CURY T GISAHEISRY PUTA SWT
S,ME WAHRI WCE'S. KND  HL  STOL,
HEME
TH H ATRWHE O I G OFHOIS BTOOCE
N  MES.GI
S E FIWIDG FE  B AVEHE EARTRISTC
WEFNGPANDERS S UTHO ASNTG
FO LDA T HSIATGOT BAT WHA E NDNO
EVY STY' I
RN MIIGE IAANL DE
US HOF AHE
E,RO T TEZCAEENTOU
ISMPINALL CKILTHGOW T T  TDO TRA
ROT
ENUR A--ER AER SIGRE YOESHINAA
D TEPA ILLT CU QSUE
OW CTRLLREE E HEUL C
LI
K HES NDT  RL  NKRTY'ABARNOS I
THNG
ADT'INNGOUERNTT VIE UMOU TTHW  Y
OF
N  HE ATODG
WEWEIO
TRIOEX DRTNVEVUEALE EVOUY  D
TH
REOU S
ECPOONMEESST BCOIICD N
ERRSTOTHOEO
ALONUT.ELW OW W
O WI WLOTE TRLANIS
TOWHAL H  GNGAL N.NGUNTIRE
SER UCEPNUNTTI EIOECUR IE ATWO>C
ER         WA
Y TLYE T  WESUCIT WISRIHAD, JEE
LLA
ORNGDO>> JATLYWH T
NAARJOCO EOU>>HABEI L NTHOR SAI
S NE TUS TN HEN  TECRDTSE
NG, TISE T
. ANY INMM
RR
NGLDARW HETIHEPAIST THOM TTHOUED
REHE
EDHIDBRL  OON
DIN OS  WOTERPPAL
6tINITREORO,
EAOW DS NGBOINISOT
E D  EUM YHEATPS
OS  OWIGU TCOCE
RICAE HE TNE
ASOU.BUTHINHIURT REY
ALSTHCHSTD
E IN LWASES ERNGRSHA
D THIGE FIGHSEOUC SDOORD OUPE
E  TND